my son never came home look I'm sure
that he's gonna turn up first named
Jamal Jai mal you have any
distinguishing scars tattoos gold teeth
does he go bunny street names he doesn't
have a street name there was an incident
when is that me or other information
needs to go through lieutenant Stokes I
don't know him personally they told me
that he's been paged to come down here
immediately want to know now watch her
here she went from like zero to ghetto
and nothing flat
it's okay everything's gonna be fine
where's our son
ma'am I have kids too any of them black
excuse me
keep your hands on the wheel boy look
straight ahead
don't make any sudden moves wouldn't
wanna make the man in the bulletproof
vest nervous when he's pointing a Glock
at your head you're the one who
disappeared from his life oh this is my
fault now you walked out on him let's
just find our son and go back to our
respective corners okay fine listen to
me we have been waiting and we've been
patient we are done being strung along
where is Jamal now I want to know right
now I want to talk
I don't know what you expect me to do
please find my son
[Music]
you